[inaudible] has a military genius,
a tactician without peer at the age of 35 having just ground himself,
the first emperor of France,
he said about conquering all of Europe.
His name was Napoleon Bonaparte,
and above all he was a master propagandist.
He made use of his extraordinary way with words,
do publish political manifestos and newspapers,
and later his autobiography,
he regularly commissioned portraits and sculptures and was acutely aware of how
to present himself in the best light.
Even when he made moves to crown himself emperor,
he used propaganda and political.
Now to convince the populace that it was their idea.
Napoleon has aroused one of two emotions,
hatred or loyalty.
Everything around him seemed bigger than life.
Yet he has none of the physical traits that we associate with power.
He was short at five foot two had extremely pale skin,
small delicate hands,
and a large head set on a short stout neck.
Despite this,
his inner self belief projected the aura of invincibility that made him a
natural leader of men.
It led him to the dizzying heights of Victory Am's,
the crushing despair of to feet.
And this week's biographics.
We discover the real Napoleon Bonaparte
in the spring of 1769 the tiny islands nation of Corsica was under siege,
a hardy bands.
Of course,
it can.
Patriots determines to repel the French army that had invaded their lambs.
They never stood a chance that after a year of fighting death and carnage,
the rebels were a fetus.
The survivors trudge through the mountains back to their homes.
Among them was that easier and Carlo Bonaparte?
Let's easier.
It was six months pregnant.
It was the day of the Feast of assumption.
On August,
1517 69 went letizia.
It gave birth to her second child and he was named Napoleon Napoleon.
His father gave up the flag.
Of course it can independence.
Once French victory was a shirt he refused to fight on in the mountains with his
former Patriot holdouts,
the 23 year old university student and ingratiated himself to the French
overlords and quickly took on the trappings of French privileged.
It was something that his second son would never forgive him for viewing his
father as a traitor who had betrayed his countryman.
Collar then entered upon a law practice.
Before long he had won election to the course of an assembly.
He became accepted among the elite.
Of course,
it can society and was viewed with favor by the French rulers.
Yes.
The more successful he became,
the more it drove a wedge between him and his second son.
In contrast to how he viewed his father,
the younger Polian Sims,
he adored his mother.
There's easier,
was a strong willed on the woman of her 13 pregnancies.
She ended up with eight children.
Oh half disciplinarian.
She would tolerate no nonsense.
We have Napoleon would lead to reminisce that all of his success in life was due
to the training of that he had received at his mother's knee,
the and set foot on the French mainland for the first time in the winter of 1778
his father having security in that position at the prestigious Royal Military
College at Brienne in northern France.
Napoleon though he hated us,
accustomed to the warmth of the Mediterranean,
the harsh climate,
shift him to the bone,
just top it off.
The skinny uncoordinated country by could hardly speak any French,
any one of the facts that he was a scholarship by into country bumpkin and the
loyal Corsican with a strange accident would have been enough to make the
bullies targets and yet somehow Napoleon accustomed himself to life at Brienne.
His stubbornness and tough exterior made him immune to the taunts of is more
privileged.
Classmates seem they,
along with his teachers,
lost interest in the Sullen,
always serious Bonaparte.
Napoleon,
he became a loner at the age of 16 Napoleon began his military apprenticeship as
a second left tenants training with the country's most elite itinerary.
Eunice.
He knows his trade well and developed into a skilled handler of arms as well as
a capable Hendra of men.
Yes,
the advancements that he had mapped out for himself was slow in coming.
He soon realized that hard work and application,
we're not enough to forge a stellar military career position and money.
They also played their part and he had neither by his late teens.
Napoleon found himself in a state of frustrated inertia.
He knew that he was destined for great things,
yet nothing was happening for him.
Simply he was bored to death.
What Napoleon needed was a cataclysmic event that would up ends the existing
order in presenting with the opportunity to grab hold of and shape the future.
Little did he know though that this was waiting just around the corner.
On July the 14th 1789 Paris erupted and revolution the spark.
There's unleashed the revolution in all its Furio card.
When a crowd's took over,
an armory called hotel to invalid,
they grabbed its weapons and stormed the Bastille prison in search of powder and
shot word spreads of the crown success ends.
Uprisings began all over France,
grand juries and manor houses.
They were overrun.
The country was in great turmoil.
20 year old Napoleon was far from Paris when revolution break forth cause they
not to revolutionary himself.
He welcomes the revolts which was shaking the system of privileges which he so
despised.
After all,
it was this very system that prevented him from achieving the advancement of
rank that he felt was due to him.
When the French republic was declared in the fall of 1792 v ambitious courses
can,
he wanted to play a pass formulating a plan.
He took a leave of absence from the army and returned to Corsica,
which was now a part of France.
He was intent on entering local politics and rising through the ranks until he
could assert its influence on the national stage.
The course it can.
Governor,
however,
Rebuff Napoleon calling him a big inexperienced boy and Napoleon reacted to this
by setting up a power base to oppose the governor.
He attracted a following of young cronies.
That's the establishment's proved too strong fan.
Napoleon was forced to flee to the mountains.
He ends.
His entire family were labeled traitors and enemies of the father lands setting
south France.
In June of 1793 Napoleon was tougher,
more steely-eyed and more hard skinned as a result of his unhappy experience in
Corsica.
The experience also caused a mental displacement.
No longer a Corsican.
Well,
he was now 30 French that France.
However,
while that was going to have to be molded to make it worthy of feminine,
if I didn't return to the army as an artillery caps him,
he was quickly ordered too,
too long.
A city of 28,000 which had broken into open rebellion.
This is dozens of this southern port.
It thrown their port,
open it to the British.
It was the French itineraries job to prevent the British from gaining a foothold
and just to subjugate the rebels.
The role of the ones that the British were defending the city from their ships,
cannons Napoleon,
and knew that he had been presented with the opportunity that could transform
his destiny.
Aristocratic officers had fled France leaving a vacuum that the Polian was all
too eager to fill.
All the had to do was simply proven itself on his commands.
Guns and suppliers were rushed in from Provence and there's gunners were taught
to Mandan.
The regular infantry were intensely retrains unto Bonaparte's direct
supervision.
He also began to display the flashes of charisma,
which would forge an unbreakable loyalty within his ranks.
On December the 17th he personally led the assault of Fort Egg.
Relate his bravery and his cunning immediately apparent,
throwing himself into the fray.
He fought with fury.
Unlike most commanders,
Napoleon led from the front.
Oh,
horse was shot out from under him and it's an enemy ban at slashed him in the
fight.
Yes,
he continued to attack and his forces quickly overcame the resistance.
Within hours,
10 British ships had been destroyed and those that remained were in retreat.
The local people,
they would then subjugate us.
It was a stunning victory for Napoleon and one that led to his promotion to
Brigadier General.
In the spring of 1795 Napoleon visited Paris has ambition burning brighter than
ever.
While there he was charged with subjugating the parisien mobs by any means
necessary.
He jumped at the opportunity grabbing cannons and muskets in order to equip is
poorly armed forces.
He said his guns up inside the tutor Rian positions that made it impregnable.
When the attack came,
Napoleon commanded his men to unleash a merciless hail of fire upon them.
Waiting until he could see the whites of their eyes.
He sends a barrage of great shots that decimated the Parisien mob.
The enemy attacks us.
We killed a great many of them.
Now we'll,
there's quiet.
I could not be happier.
The podium wrote to his brother,
Napoleon was triumphant.
Within a month,
he had been made a full general I just 26 years of age.
He was the commander of the army of the interior.
Okay.
As a reward for his success against the Parisien mobs was given command of the
French army in Italy.
There he was charged with defeating France,
his enemies,
the Austrians,
along with that Italian allies to push them back over the Alps.
This was his first opportunity to fight on foreign soil,
and Napoleon was determined to capitalize on this.
Prior to his arrival,
Napoleon's generals had already written him off as a new accounts upstart with
illusions of grand.
Yet when Bonaparte's arrived in the flashes,
generals quickly realized their mistake.
They had vastly underestimated.
Then you Camada.
He quickly put them in that place.
For nearly two years,
there in competence had seen the French forces stagnating in the Alps with
nothing to show for it,
but a general sense of apathy and discontent as the generals bit their lips.
Napoleon addressed the troops.
Soldiers,
you are naked and deal fed.
No fame shines upon you.
I will lead you into the most fertile plains in the world.
Rich provinces and great city as well lie in your power.
You will find their honor,
glory and riches.
The men were enraptured by their new leader smiling and laughing in the midst.
It was unlike anything I had ever seen before.
He picks up their spirits and made them believe in themselves and infusing them
with passion.
He began molding them into eight formidable fighting force.
Meanwhile,
the other European powers had become very nervous about what was going on in
France.
The execution of their king and queen led to the fears that the French
experiments in democracy would spreads am's threat and their own kingdoms.
This led them to quickly move against the new French government.
This led to a series of wars between France and most of the major European
powers,
the of built his army into the most efficient conquering force on the European
mainland.
Over the next three years.
He brought stunning victories,
not only in Italy,
but as far as Australia and parts of North Africa.
There's a north African invasion force was actually moving it's Britain,
which used Egypt as a trading route,
though he failed to bring Egypt under control,
Napoleon was greeted as a hero on,
it's returned to Paris in 1799 yet he founds a nation in Tamale.
The governments had no money.
The Austrians and the Russians were threatening to invade and some people even
wanted to bring back the royal family.
Rumors were flying of a cube with the people on the army behind him.
Napoleon at took charge of the grand assembly installing a new government that
was to be headed by three provisional consults,
one of these three men with Napoleon Bonaparte himself,
and it was he who everyone knew was going to wield the power.
Immediately.
Napoleon took control.
He sidelined the other two consoles personally rewriting the constitution to
make himself the first consult.
At 30 years of age,
Napoleon Bonaparte had risen from his humble Corsican backgrounds to become the
most powerful
man in France
as the absolute central power in France.
Napoleon had inherited a nation that had limped from one failed attempt to to
replace the rule of monarchy to another.
For many people,
the conditions they found themselves in at the dawn of the 19th century were
worse than before the revolution.
They looked in Napoleon to save them from their dispatch.
First though he had to save them from the Austrians.
The Austrians had regrouped and gains back and most of the lands that Napoleon
had secured during the Italian campaign,
the arch Duke Francis.
The second was intent on crushing the course that can use he thought he could do
as he pleased,
as was his custom.
Napoleon decided to take the offensive in the spring of 1800 he took his 40,000
strong army across the French Alps.
It was a harrowing track,
has men dragging field artillery and provisions up steep snow covered mountain
rangers,
which towers to a height of 10,500 feet.
Men Donnie's on reason and there's the grand army stumbled through this and
Bernard Pass.
They were in a state of utter exhaustion,
but the crossing it had made in just six days.
The battle was joined on June the 14th and at the day's end,
7,000 Frenchmen lay debt.
The Austrians who would finally retreat in from the field of battle left 14,000
bodies behind the totally spans grand army.
They had one again.
The Austrians withdrew and early the next year signed a peace treaty with
Napoleon.
Great Britain was the only country remaining in the podiums weight.
He was simply the supreme ruler of the land mass that was Europe.
However,
Great Britain has unquestioned command of the seas and fabulously Richard.
This point due to how colonial conquest since boasting the greatest navy in the
wells Briston decided it was time to holds the rise of the little general
president declared war on France on May the 18th 1803 and it was at this point
in the Napoleon decided it was time to invade England,
displaying the laser like focus that epitomize the man.
He stated,
all my thoughts aren't directed towards England's.
I want only for a favorable winds.
Two plants,
the Imperial Eagle on the Tower of London.
As it turns out though,
the French invasion of Great Britain never materialized by September,
1805 war with Austria.
Now fortified by the Russians was once again a priority.
If the ground's army was being rushed from the coast,
do the heart of the Austrian empire.
Then on October the 21st the Royal Navy,
it smashed the combined Spanish British fleet in the battle of Trafalgar,
leaving the French essentially without a navy.
The British that left them safe.
The now on December,
the second day's here for Napoleon had crowned himself as the first emperor of
the French in a lavish ceremony in all but name and place.
It was just lengthy coronation of the old kings,
which with one telling difference,
Napoleon that you controller of his own fates,
place the crown,
all 80 jewel encrusted pounds of it upon his own head.
Okay.
On December the second day,
you know,
five Napoleon found himself again poised for Massell against Austria.
This time,
four to five by Russia,
this would prove to be the little general,
his greatest victory.
He deliberately abandoned a strategic position near the town of Wooster in the
Austrian empire.
So that his army,
which numbered around 68,000 would appear vulnerable.
He then weakened his right flank,
so it was to look the 90,000 strong flow into a trap if they their center open
to counter attack and the pony and cut the line in two by 4:30 PM the allies
were either dead or foreign retreat.
The battlefields have simply fallen silent.
The Battle of Austerlitz just like that was over what it began as a great allied
opportunity to finally defeat and destroy.
Napoleon Bonaparte had ended not only in their defeat,
but in catastrophe.
The grounds victory at [inaudible] was followed up with a 21 day subjugation of
pressure.
Over the next five years.
Victory followed victory as one by one.
The European powers bowed to the dictates of Emperor Napoleon only at one
European nation remains to be brought to heel.
Russia
[inaudible] is a colossal army across the Newman River run June the 24th 1812 to
intimidate Russia,
but it turns out to be the undoing of his empire.
The Russians systematically retreated and scorched the earth,
which drags the French deep into their territory.
Then when they did do battle,
it was the bloodiest day of Napoleon's Korea.
The French entered Moscow.
A week later,
I need to find it evacuated.
The retreat ended up being even more costly.
Soldiers had insufficient clothing for the freezing temperatures of an early
Windsor disease,
devastated the ranks and Russian forces pursued them all the way.
A little over a six of the 600,000 men who marched into Russia came home.
This was a blow from which the little general would never recover by now for the
political map of Europe,
it had changed the British,
the Spanish,
the Portuguese pushed the French Bac over the Pyrenees in dependency,
love walk.
A grand coalition was formed with the decisive victory coming at the battle of
Leipzig in October of 1813 known as the battle of the nations that left 38,000
French dead or wounded and 20 thousands captured.
Yeah.
Napoleon escapes only defines open hostility back in Paris.
The legislative assembly,
the centers,
and even his own general stands on him.
He has no choice but to advocate,
which he did.
So in April of [inaudible] 1814 it was agreed that Napoleon would be sent into
exile on the Mediterranean island of Elba.
After 10 months of exome,
the Polian had had enough somehow on the night of February the 26th 1850 and he
managed to sneak past his gods and set sail in a small boat for the mother
country within a handful of loyal soldiers.
Miraculously,
they managed to avoid the British warships,
stepping foot back on French soil.
He fixed his sights on Paris and it's taking back what had been torn from
heaven.
After six days in just few men were halted by an infantry regiments with strict
orders to detain him,
the podium straight ahead of his followers and stood in their midst.
Soldiers either clouds if there is one among you who wants to kill his general
and emperor.
Here I am.
His charisma that's done it again rather than rush to taken captive the massed
infantry broken to wild applause.
Cheers of long live.
The emperor filled the air.
Suddenly he had an army.
As he closed it on Paris,
he drew more and more support in one place.
Softer and other treats defected from the royal army and joined the rebel army,
the writing that it was on the wall.
By the time you arrived in Paris,
let me the 18th and flat.
The podium was back in command.
The people,
they welcomed him as a redeemed here,
right
across Europe.
The allies were in shock and disbelief.
The devil,
it had been unchanged.
They would have to unite one more time to stop him.
This time though,
they would have to totally destroy the man so that there was no chance he would
come back.
Napoleon was declared an outlaw and a disturber of the tranquility of the wells.
They mask their armies for attack.
The great reckoning it was that happens,
it would be delivered on a field of Rye and clover just outside of a small
Belgian town called Waterloo.
On June the 18th 72,000 French soldiers face day 68,000 strong allied force
under the Duke of Wellington.
While the fighting seemed even Napoleon made many tactical errors including
launching his imperial guard too late.
Here's the most fatal error was to wait until midday before ordering his initial
attack.
In order to the last of the muddy ground dry.
This gave the Prussians time do enter the fray.
Later on,
they smash it against his right flank and the battle was lost.
Four days later,
Napoleon abdicated again,
but this time it would be no return.
He was packed off to the remote British colony of Santa Elena at 46 Napoleon was
simply a man without a future,
the man of unstoppable ambition,
the man of action,
the amount of headlines he was confined to reading the newspaper and gardening.
He died on May the fifth 1821 most likely from stomach cancer days before when
he knew his time was up,
he had whispered to to one of his gods to die is nothing but to live defeated
and without glory is to die every day.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button.
Doesn't do what it used to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the rice,
and as always,
thank you for watching.
[inaudible].